κάθε χρόνο είμαστε πάρα πολύ πιο ψηλά στο πο και από θέμα παιδιά αυτή τι
τημέ έχουμε γύρω στα ενανιτα πέντε μεκατόν παιδι ξεκίνη θα θυμα με την πρώτ την
μέρα είχα τέσσρα παιδιά δύ ότην πρώτην ώρα και δύ ότι δευτερινόν όκι είχαμε τρεις
γυμναστές γιατραβίει μα στε παραβάνε ηγιναστες που τα παιδιά αυτή τις στημέχουμε γύρωσι τα εκατό
παιδάγια γυμνάζονται κάπνο κάποιες δράσεις απόαπό την άλμα κάποιες σημερίτες αθλητικές για να διασκεδάζουν τα
παιδιά και από το είχας κοστρία έχουμε κάνι αίτοιμα αφού έχουμε πιστοποιηθεί από παντού έχουμε
κάνι αίτοιμα προς την ομοσποντία να γίνουμε νο εβδομοσύλλογος τακτικό μέλος στην ουσία τις σκοαιά
τις όμως ποντίας του στίβου και ν απάντηση ι απάντηση ταν αρνητική στην ουσιάν οι
απάντηση απαντήθηκε μετά αποκτομήνες τον απρίλλι του κερα ότι για ναγίνει θέλουμενα πληρείσε αυτά τι
αυτά μου ζητή αντέρος πάνντων κάποια αλλά γίνειτρόυ και λοιπά τα οποία πριν δυομήνες αφού
έχου μαζεψει όλα αυτά που μουζητήσα πριν δύομήνες έχουμε στείλεη την απάντηση μας μετα διιολογητικά
που μουζητήθηκαν πρμεσήμερα δεν έχωυ καμιά αν απάντηση θεωρο για να ημοπαντήσουν ότι μάλλον κάτι
άλλον νακαλύψαση γιατί μεταξύ άλλον κιίνο πουμο απαντήσα σε ανακαλευτικαι να ς νόμος στο χλια
νια κόσογοντα έξ γι τα θελητικά μητρόα αφιβάλλω ανυπόλεπη η συλλόγι έχουν έστω κε κάποιον
αθλτικώ μήτρο πάρε όλ αυτά αναγκάζομε στην ουσία γιατί μποροέχω μια ακατειμία ενέα σωματίω μεγαλώ
νήμέρα με την ημέρα ο στόχος μου είναι να βοηθήσουμε ο αναθλισμό στην κύπρο δυστυχώς
στα πράγματα στον γκλαστικό ανθισμό δενκαι τα καλύτερα και το πις και τοια αταποκρισή σίγουρακάνες
καιρεύτερες κέψεις αναξίζει ακριβο